[Musique]
la chronique de l'cho comme chaque jeudi
sur TV fil 78 dans le 78 oui Wilfried
alors cette chronique économie sera en
deux parties hein tout d'abord le Mois
de l'économie sociale et solidaire on le
disait et puis on parlera emploi et
handicap à l'occasion d'un forum
organisé à l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin c'était ce jeudi
guimalandin maire de trappe à vos côtés
Florent Dupuit de l'association igren
qui œuvre pour l'éducation au
développement durable pour commencer
cette séquence je vous propose de
débuter par un micro trottoir nous avons
demandé aux 50tinois ce qu'était
l'économie sociale et solidaire on
regarde leur
réponse ce serait une économie qui
penserait avant tout à toute la société
euh ce serait ce qu'on peut dire une
politique socialiste je pense solidire
c'est les les riches qui payent pour les
pauvres et ainsi de suite euh l'économie
sociale ça peut commencer par le le
logement à des prix raisonnables ça peut
commencer par des des aides pour les les
crèches par exemple peut-être revoir
revoir ou modifier les allocations
familiales faut partager euh les plus
riches partagent avec les moins riches
je pense que c'est ça pour moi
l'économie sociale c'est le partage ce
qui se passe dans le monde entier là
c'est que il y a pas de partage donc euh
il il y a des gens qui sont en bas et
puis qui qui se relont jamais hein
solidaire pourquoi bah essayer de mettre
en commun toutes les richesses pour
pouvoir en faire profiter à tout le
monde euh bon après je suis pas un
spécialiste en économie mais qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait dire d'autre voilà je
pense c'est ça avant tout qui est
important c'est le côté
social Florent dupu est-ce que toutes
ces définitions vous surprennent est-ce
que certaines sont exactes je suis
plutôt agréablement surpris par les
définitions déjà je suis surpris que
vous ayz pas eu de personne qui vous
aient dit que il ne voyent pas du tout
ce que c'était parce que j'en croise
régulièrement après elles sont elles
sont pour la plusupart exacte mais un
petit peu restrictif parce que
l'économie sociale et solidaire ça va
au-delà de l'action sociale euh on peut
pratiquer un grand nombre d'activités en
étant dans l'économie sociale et
solidaire une coopérative d'artistes une
association de sport font partie de
l'économie sociale et solidaire donc
pour rappeler un peu les choses ce sont
des entreprises au sens large
responsables qui on en fait une autre
vision de l'économie comme vous le dis
on trouve des coopératives des mutuels
des associations comme la vôtre des
structures donc de l'insertion par
l'activité économique des fondations et
elles sont présentes dans dans tous les
secteurs d'activité on trouve des
assurances des banques dans la culture
le sport vous le disiez même le commerce
équitable on en connaît beaucoup en fait
sans le savoir artisan du monde emus
même le Crédit coopératif ou encore la
massif Florent dupi pourquoi un mois
consacré à l'économie sociale et
solidaire et puis on parlait de benoî
Hamont aussi hein qui est délégué pour
pour ce secteur en particulier il y
avait un besoin de de vitrine pour cette
activité alors ça fait l'économie
sociale et solidaire est pas toute neuve
hein elle existe depuis le le 19e siècle
des associations des coopérative existe
depuis très longtemps mais on a
effectivement un problème de visibilité
auprès du grand public et pour parti
auprès des décideurs aussi donc ce moi
c'est d'abord l'occasion de faire
connaître ce qu'est l'économie sociale
et solidaire au grand public de montrer
la diversité de ce qu'on peut y faire de
ce qu'on peut y faire en tant que
travailleur en tant que citoyen en tant
que
consommateur et puis c'est aussi
l'occasion de rassembler tous les
acteurs de l'économie sociale et
solidaire qui souvent se connaissent
entre structures qui agissent dans le
même secteur mais qui se connaissent
assez mal d'un secteur à un autre alors
l'économie sociale et solidaire vous
nous dites c'est pas tout neuf même si
on a effectivement l'impression de ouvr
aujourd'hui puisquil y a un ministère de
l'économie sociale et solidaire qui est
porté par Benoît amamont quelques
chiffres peut-être Alice pour voir ce
que ça représente cette économie sociale
c'est vrai que c'est assez conséquent on
va le voir à l'écran l'économie sociale
et solidaire en France c'est 9,5 % des
entreprises soit 220000
établissements et puis plus de 10,3 %
des salariés en France soit plus de 2
millions de salariés on trouve 65 % de
femmes une proportion qui détonne un
petit peu avec le secteur privé ou
public hors économie et soci et
solidaire et puis une proportion élevée
aussi de seniors 27 % contre 21 % dans
le reste de l'économie privée
guimalandin vous êtes maire d'une ville
d'environ 30000 habitants comment est-ce
que ce type d'économie s'inscrit dans la
vie de la
cité dans dans un choix dans un choix
politique d'abord nous
avons commencé à accueillir des
dispositifs des organisations de faisant
partie de ce qu'on appelle l'économie
sociale et solidaire en 2005 euh avec
Artisans du Monde que que nous
hébergeons le terme convient peut-être
pas enfin qui a été accueilli accueilli
attrapé puis en en 2008 j'ai voulu que
nous ayons un élu qui qui est Madame
beaujand donc une élu qui soit délégué à
l'économie sociale et solidaire puisque
nous finalement nous sommes aperçus que
ça correspondait à nos choix politiques
à nos options politiques alors il faut
pas faut pas dire que tout tout le
modèle économique nationale et mondiale
doit être bâti sur cette théorie mais il
y a il y a social et solidaire ça veut
dire que la personne dans le cadre d'une
action économique qui a son budget ses
équilibres ça ses prestations ses
fournitures sa professionnalisation il y
a des méthodes de gestion les
coopératives les associations de
production et cetera qui sont des
méthodes qui change de la méthode
capitaliste classique he qui a sa place
mais qui ne peut pas avoir toute sa
place la preuve le nombre que que vous
venez de de citer alors nous avons euh
une collection hein si je puis dire
enfin une part importante dans
d'entreprises qui sont euh inséré dans
dans dans la vie de de la ville nous
avons une entreprises des entreprises
euh d'économie sociale et solidaire à la
pépinière d'entreprise à Promopole nous
en avons qui sont installés euh dans
différents magasins nous venons
d'acheter euh la ville hein nous venons
d'acheter une librairie qui allait
fermer pour y y installer la librairie
Le milfoil qui est qui est une
association euh d'économie sociale et
solidaire il fabriqueent il répare il
ils vendent je veux dire il y a il y a
un équilibre économique et puis euh
dernier dernier cadeau de la ville a
fallu beaucoup travailler pour y
parvenir et donc tous mes tous mes
collègues et moi-même nous y sommes
donnés c'est l'accueil de la première
implantation de la fédération on envie
en île-de-fance qui se qui est ouverte
maintenant qui se fait attrappe et et
qui inser et qui
intègre des des des personnes qui
étaient soit de vrais professionnels he
soit qui étaient en attente d'emploi et
que on va inaugurer le jeudi prochain en
présence de beno d'Ur excuse-moi voilà
alors on voit bien que votre ville hein
la politique que vous développé c'est de
faciliter ce ce type d'économie mais
Florent dupu quelles sont les
difficultés au auxquelles se heur en
fait ces structures alors il y a des
difficultés de de plusieurs natures la
première c'est comme on est sur une
structure ce sont des des entreprises de
personnes et pas des entreprises de
capitaux donc la première difficulté
c'est de réussir à faire comprendre ça
lorsqu'on veut développer un projet
lorsqu'on a des investissements réalisés
de faire comprendre ça à des financeurs
potentiels et quand on a une forme qui
est plus originale de structure parce
que les association on les connaît assez
bien mais sur des formes de coopératives
comme les SCOP les sociétés coopératives
et participativ comme les SK les
sociétés coopératives d'intérêt
collectif c'est très difficile et nous
les acteurs qu'on rencontre
régulièrement nous font ces remontter de
réussir à entreprendre des démarches
administratives des démarches de
recherche de financement parce que on
est assez peu connu et il y a une
difficulté à à montrer la crédibilité de
ces ces modèles et justement vous parlez
des difficultés de financement un forum
a été organisé c'était en début de
semaine pour aider les associations dans
leur recherche de financement c'était
une table ronde organisée à manilamo en
début de semaine nous y étions on
regarde ensemble ce
reportage comment trouver des
financements quand on est une
association c'était la thématique d'un
forum organisé à la Maison de
l'Environnement à manilé àamo à
l'occasion du Mois de l'économie sociale
et solidaire une forme d'économie
responsable qui concerne 9,5 % des
entreprises de France et plus de 10 %
des salariés parmi les acteurs présents
deux structures départementales qui
accompagnent les associations dans leur
développement comment rechercher des
subventions et et comment les péréniser
puce qu' aujourd'hui avec la baisse des
subventions les associations doivent
réfléchir aussi à d'autres sources de
financement on est énormément en ce
moment sur la la recherche de subvention
diversifier les sources de financement
le contexte de la crise touche également
les et surtout les les structures de
l'économie sociale et solidaire autre
conseil bien remplir les dossiers de
demande de financement auprès des
structures publiques pour multiplier ces
chances de nombreux rendez-vous sont à
retrouver dans les Yvelines jusqu'à fin
novembre toutes les informations sont
sur le site du Mois de l'économie
sociale et
solidaire et justement tous ces
rendez-vous Florent dupuie vous pouvez
nous en donner quelques-uns alors parmi
les rendez-vous qui ont lieu sur la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentins en Yveline donc outre
cette journée que nous avons organisé
hier avec la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentins en yeline vont être
organisé donc une conférence débat
organisée par la ville de trappe jeudi
prochain le 22 en présence de benoî
amont sur la thématique des coopératives
c'est ouvert au public c'est ouvert au
public à tous ceux qui veulent venir euh
un àh30 c'est à 20h30 à l'auditorium de
Musique de la Ville de trappe merci euh
nous faisons une animation à la Maison
de l'Emploi et de la Formation le 26
donc là donc att trpe c'est ouvert
également publ sur inscription euh est
organisé à la faculté de 50 ans neline
un village avec de nombreuses structures
deéconomie sociale et solidaire le but
est de les faire découvrir aux étudiant
suivi d'une conférence débat avec le
mouvement pour l'économie solidaire
c'est quel jour c'est le 2 suite et on
termine par une intervention de Benoît
amont qui nous a fait l'honneur de venir
une deuxième fois sur le territoire de
550 an sera très présent du côté de
sa-tin nveline voilà les prochaines
semaines et dernier événement c'est à la
Maison de l'environnement des sciences
et du développement durable le 30
novembre à 20h30 une action de théâtre
forum intitulé La bataille d'alisia sur
les coopératives ben à moi chargé et je
rajoute à tout cet agenda un autre
rendez-vous donc ce weekend artisan du
monde organise une expo vente à
Versailles au centre 8 euh voilà donc
c'est huit portes de la h huit rues de
la porte de Buc
excusez-moià euh voilà donc samedi et
dimanche toute la journée merci Alice on
va poursuivre la page Cho merci à nos
deux invités d'êtreevenenu merci
également guimalandin d'avoir répondu à
nos différentes questions